بدات السلطات الصينيه تخفيفا لاجراءات
المتعلقه بفايروس كورونا في بيجين وعدد من
المدن الكبرى هذا واعلن عده مناطق في
بيجين عدم مطالبه من يبقون في منازلهم ولا
يذهبون الى الاماكن العامه باختبارات
كورونا اليوميه كما اعلنت مراكز التسوق في
العاصمه الصينيه انها ستعيد فتح ابوابها
اعتبارا من اليوم الخميس
والجنوبيه البلاد رفعت حاله الاغلاق في
معظم المناطق كما اعلنت سلطات المدينه
الاستئناف عمل سلاسل النقل والانشطه
التجاريه واجراء تعديلات على تدابير
الوقايه
هذا هو قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
جاو ليجيان انه لا يحق للولايات المتحده
انتقاده فعاليه التدابير المتخذه في بلاده
لمواجهه كورونا وان ذلك وان تلك التدابير
حققت نتائج ايجابيه وفق تعبيره
لدى الولايات المتحده كثير من المشاكل
المحليه حالات الاصابه والوفاه بفيروس
كورونا المستجد فيها هي الاعلى عالميا ولا
يحق لواشنطن انتقاده فعاليات الصين في
الوقايه من الاوب او مكافحتها ما يجب ان
تفعله هو الرد بجديه على مطالب بشعبها
والقيام بعملها بشكل جيد